[Musique]
et c'est toujours la même chose au début
c'est dingue et après dexter descend un
peu les mecs me dire comme une merde à
temps non mais je me suis bien fait
baiser je viens qui au sens propre comme
au sens figuré d'ailleurs les allemands
plus un nom comme cette ville qui vous
dégoûte maintenant paris capitale de la
mode pour moi ça veut dire pas de bar au
petit chien mais quand il s'agit de
bourrer la gueule julien il ya du monde
tu te rends compte ça fait cinq ans
qu'on est ensemble et on se connaît pas
c'est fou moi des fois j'ai l'impression
que tu pars en partage de points en 22
secondes loyer le space co
comme ça
ouais la route ce week end c'est quoi
cette fixette sur l'italie non mais je
sais pas mais je dis l'italie parce que
tu te sentes pas aller plus loin que ce
que tu as peur de la nouvelle excuse moi
c'est hyper dangereux comment ça marche
ça vole bas
non mais c'est parce qu'on part en
vacances ensemble de semaine que tous
les deux donc ya un petit truc quoi rien
n'y a pas de trucs
non j'étais disposé des dispose en plus
moi je pensais tu étais fait nos courses
entraînés ensemble c'est tout
oui non mais enfin mais on n'est pas en
couple c'est ça le gêne moi c'est bien
on continue à être un plan cul plus plus
et on quitte pas ensemble par en couple
on va au lourd il ya que les coupes qui
vont lourds ou les familles et quand on
est ronde
je crois qu est ce que tu dis c'est
parce que tu respires pas assez sa focus
ou c'est pas bon pour l'enfant
allez allez allez plus de 40 ans
qui se souvient au début il voulait
rompre avec moi mais c'est parce que ça
allait trop vite j'avais peur gériatre a
dit avoir rappelé si je faisais juste ça
très déçu j'avais des enfants
j'adore
[Musique]
je suis sacré avec
c'est con parce qu'on a pas mal de
parents comment tu vois même un niveau
de la bouffe
moi je suis sans gluten totalement fou
tu bouffes tout ouais ouais il cinéma
aussi star wars c'est pas ta pas vu ce
que je disais moi non plus ouais c'est
ça ce que je sens qu'en ce moment il n'a
plus trop envie de me voir j'ai dit un
truc qu'il fallait pas où louis mais non
c'est manu vrai parce que la dernière
fois on a eu un petit débat politique
assez houleux je te cache pas tu me
connais et j'ai senti tu sais